beth it's good to see you
i love the red i feel like you're in a
good place now you have good energy
going on right now
i mean you fought to the end what are
you most proud of
about your game and being in this house
what's that three what are you most
proud of
about your game and being in this house
i'm really really proud that i never
ever ever stopped
even if it wasn't the best move
sometimes i never ever gave up in that
house
really really really proud of that um
and i love who i chose to work with
again even if it didn't work out at the
end
i love the family yeah can we talk about
that discussion with ty in the kitchen
got pretty intense and
i don't know what was happening who was
lying who saw the truth what is going on
so
what what was going on there with ty
break it
i don't even know what's going on with
ty right now
he
i broke his trust pretty hard when
kiefer made that final three with me and
i didn't go to him
he was my number one in the game and i
should have went to him i should have
told him
he was super upset about that and i get
it but i
was upset that he wasn't owning up to
anything in the game and i told him
that's not how you're gonna win big
brother you gotta have some moves under
your belt
man so we'll see and
when jed left i feel like your game went
a little bit down
just a little bit you were so strong
crossing your arm and sitting on the
chair
was that the reason you're here sitting
with me talking to me right now
um yeah i think
i totally underestimated how close
brayden and ty and kiefer were i thought
i had them in my back pocket i thought i
had set myself up that i didn't meet jed
anymore
right that wasn't the case if judd was
there i think i would have been
who would have been a little stronger
together
hindsight 20 20. yeah what did you learn
about yourself being in the house i mean
this is an experience a mental game it's
a physical game
and spiritual game yeah all around
um i'm a lot stronger than i thought it
was
100 that especially that past week that
was a really really tough one on me
but i did it i'm so proud of myself i'm
so proud of how far i got
um i'm super shocked at you know how
good i was at building relationships
with people in the house
game and personal i'm happy with it
oh personal yes we saw a little
flirtation going on between you and jed
and ty just a little
and you also mentioned in your la in
your speech the fact that you were part
of one of the most diverse house guests
it is it was an incredible journey to
watch you guys all work together what
did it mean for you to be part of season
nine
my gosh so much the second we walked
the second i walked into that house that
was the first thing i noticed it's such
a diverse cast
i was so proud to be a part of it um
and i found that throughout the whole
season we were all we all just respected
each other
it was you know put game aside
we built such strong relationships with
each other i am so happy that i was part
of that season in particular
okay i'm gonna say a few names and let
me know what comes to your mind okay
keeper okay gamer i love keeper i am so
happy that i worked with keeper this
season however
him staying in that house ruined my game
he should have went home
jetson jetson one of the greatest men i
have
ever met in and outside of the house
should have kept him around should have
been a little more loyal
to him but we'll see what happens
outside of the game
brayden love brayden so much he's a
wonderful human being
he took care of me in that house i feel
like we kind of took care of each other
um being on opposite ends of the house
too the entire time
but i will love him forever we are
forever friends
victoria spice tv
she had a little too many she had too
many relationships in the house
to the point where i could not trust her
hands the back door
but she was loyal to me i guess in the
end and i didn't realize that until it
was too late
but one again such a great woman we're
both social workers we are going to be
close outside of this game
i love that so who do you want to win
season nine
i want tara to win and i
won't be mad at fifa wins it's between
those two and i am
super happy if they represent our season
and who do you not want to in season
nine
my bitterness and me says skye oh
we have to no we're fine i just feel
like the other house guests have really
stepped their games up and have been
playing so so hard
he has to but
yeah we'll see i get it i get it
congratulations to you coming this far
and it was wonderful watching your game
and you were and you were spicy too
let's just say it uh
and uh you had a game play that was
absolutely amazing so
thank you beth and uh look forward to
seeing the future
thanks everyone so much